all right you're done let's take a look
at the solution now we're gonna need
some text views first of all let's look
at our linear layout its vertical we're
gonna want it to be horizontal the next
thing we're gonna want are a bunch of
text views let's just drag them in now
remember we had all those IDs that were
given to us in the last quiz the first
one is the list item date textview and
we'll give it some text that makes sense
we help to layout the layout will remove
this before we actually submit it to our
project and for fun let's switch to
landscape it'll make things a little bit
more legible also let's just zoom in a
little bit all right so that's our list
item date textview now right next to
that we want another textview since we
want the design to be the same this one
doesn't need to have an ID if you
remember our design had the date
followed by a dash followed by the
forecast followed by a dash followed by
the hi followed by a slash followed by
low so this is just going to be a view
that contains a dash and we can even
hard-code this in for now then we're
gonna create another text view next to
that our placeholder text will be a
forecast like clear the ID for this one
will be list item forecast textview now
we need another textview once again this
one's not going to have an ID because we
don't need it and we'll add another dash
now we're actually getting to the high
and low forecasts let's say a high of 23
one more plain text view this one with a
slash and once again with no ID and for
a high forecast
it better be list item high textview
finally we'll add one more plain text
view this one will be for our low and of
course that means it's going to be list
item low textview and there we have it
our multiple textview layout now we
might want to make this prettier
but this is a good start and it displays
the four fields we were asked for
they're all part of a linear layout
before we actually would submit this
let's remove the placeholder text for
everything except for the static fields
we'll also have to remove these empty
IDs it's actually important to
understand what's going on in these text
views and there we have it that's what
your layout should look like at least if
you want to make it look almost
identical to the thigh out we started
out with of course you can go wild with
these designs and there's a lot you can
do with the lad editor and with
different kinds of layouts we'll be
learning more about that in the next
lesson alright we finally get to start
hooking this up to our UX let's go back
to forecastfragment